[Music]
thein
hello
[Music]
perfect
hello everybody R what's up wait a
minute three girls one wife something is
missing this guy there's my
boys I know you love your D go on say it
d d y yes of course he loves you he just
he just doesn't show it on his face or
with his body language right crew junor
come
on grou I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what Maxim Nal has escaped from prison
I'm coming for my revenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it has my I love this place
look she the most important part of a
heist is being aware of potential
dangers I traed
[Music]
myself
watch out watch out watch out watch out
no
what
intrud
thanks
Ron fire in
the